hey guys today we're going to share some
simple tricks on lighting women
hi my name is jerry gionis i'm a wedding
portrait and fashion photographer
i've been photographing for 27 years and
teaching for 20.
i'm going to share some of that
experience with you right now and share
some
simple tricks and tips on lighting women
and how to go from this to this and
don't forget
please click the link below or right up
here and you can actually download
my portrait quick start for free enjoy
okay so you have a girl in front of you
where do you start how do you light her
what's going to compliment her what's
going to bring out a shape
well here's the thing i want to first
establish the way i would traditionally
pose
a full-length uh girl and i'll show you
how we do it
in this case if she stands flat-footed
basically looking right at the camera so
do that for me
if you stand flat for a look in the
camera there's sort of really not much
shape we're photographing her at her
widest it's not going to look that great
so what we need to do is this we need to
basically turn her body so turn towards
me for the moment
we need to point her toe towards the
camera slide the heel back
bend the knee in shoulders back lean the
chest forward and then arch the back a
little bit and for the sake of the
argument put your hands on your hips
so right now we have beautiful curves
things are looking great
but we need to also have lighting that
complements the pose
now traditionally for a guy and if you
have a light source you would turn the
guy's
body towards the light source which
would basically make his chest and
shoulders which defines the male
form towards the light source and if we
bring that body part closer to the light
source as well we emphasize it
now with girls it's actually quite the
opposite we want to turn the body away
from the light source and then turn the
face back in not always but mostly
especially if you're photographing let's
say a model
um anywhere from like say a 12 13 year
old and upwards and if you want to
complement curves and you want to bring
out the beautiful shape
this is what we're going to do turn the
body away from the light turn the face
back
in i'm going to keep on saying this
until you remember it but i'm going to
prove it to you why
and looking at the nuances of where the
light's coming from
in relationship to her body and what's
going to work best for her in terms of
her skin and her shape and all these
different things let's go to the camera
and let's work this out
so traditionally what we would normally
do is if we see a light source
whether it's an open garage door whether
it's a window whether it's an actual
softbox
whatever it may be if we see that light
source we are often tempted to turn her
body towards that light source
let's just turn your body towards that
light source just about there perfect
all right we'll take a little shot like
that
now although rainey's got a great figure
i would say that if you have a mere
mortal in front of your camera
let's say who's a little bit fuller in
the body let's say a bride or a girl
who's a bit fuller in the body wearing a
white dress or a lighter dress
if you turn her body towards the light
source she's going to look bigger and
broader
and that's going to be a problem now
again rainey's got a great figure she
gets away with it but we can actually
bring out the best in her with some
subtle changes
so if all of a sudden if she turns her
body now a little bit more towards me so
just face me perfectly
okay bring your hands down just for the
sake of the argument again we're
photographing
her in a very flat environment
okay so her legs are parted her hands
are by her side
it's a pretty boring way of
photographing a girl but here's the
thing
if i want to photograph rainy front on
i at least have the light coming from
the side now if you can see where i am
in relationship to rainy i'm actually
close to the direction of light so the
light is over there but i'm actually
more on this angle shooting this way
but what i want to do is if i shoot her
directly
front on you'll start to see some
changes in the shadows of her body
we deliberately got her to wear a small
little dress and white so we can see the
shadows falling on her body
so let's do that okay so now i'm
directly in front of her we're actually
photographing her full length let's do
this
again so again with no finesse hands by
your side
looking right here all right
okay so again nothing's going on there's
just no finesse no
nothing at all we do have light coming
from the side though so my suggestion is
this
if you have to photograph or you want to
photograph a girl front on
at least have the light coming from the
side now watch what happens when you
look at her body
and it subtly turns this way so turn
that way stop there
now we start to see more shadow on her
body and
now in fact her chest and the front part
of her body are in shadow only the side
of hers in light
but watch what happens when we so slowly
turn her stop
and now we're starting to see more
shadow on her body slightly different to
before let's do that
looking this way so if you look at the
photographs that i'm showing you
even a slight little difference we're
bringing out some more shadow
now it's going to be more evident when
we actually pose her effectively
so watch what happens if we actually
turn her body towards a light source
like we did before stop there
too much come back just there good all
right
so now we're liking making her look
bigger and broader although we are
getting a shadow
on this side of her body now
here's what i want you to do i want you
to turn her body away from the light
source and the face back in as we
suggested earlier in this broadcast
so what i want you to do is point your
toe towards me
slide the heel back in bend the knee and
then shoulders back
hands on the hips there now very subtly
i want you to keep on turning now watch
rainey's going to actually
turn very slowly and i want to turn to a
point where i can see a shadow
on her cleavage in the middle of the
dress and we'll see what happens so
let's start from shadow
okay now very subtly keep on turning
this way
keep on turning stop good do this for me
again
just like that and now lean your upper
body towards the window
gorgeous and now turn your face towards
that way now if you can a little bit
more so
turn and turn your face perfect
gorgeous all right look at the
difference so now we're seeing a shadow
on the on her cleavage in the middle of
the dress her
actual bending the knees causing that
shadow was basically as well
and we turn her face towards a light
source and
it is so much better do you see what i'm
trying to say it's such an easy way of
photographing we often feel and our
instinct is telling us
the first time we ever picked up a
camera whether it's an iphone a dslr
we say turn your turn your body towards
uh wherever the light's coming from and
we photographer accordingly
but now we're bringing out a beautiful
curves we're bringing out some shadows
and
arguably more important the way the
light's coming from is where we take the
light away and that's those
shadows so let's go a little bit closer
so we understand those nuances a little
bit more
by photographing three-quarter okay so
stand flat to the camera again
okay good so we are photographing her
front on
but at least we have the light coming
from the side so at least the shadows
are giving us some depth and dimension
and shape
but again when we start pointing the toe
towards the camera
sliding that heel back bending that knee
hands on the hips for example
and as you can see her body just turns
slightly this way stop
and then lean your upper body towards
the light source and then turn your face
more towards the light
gorgeous and
now that's going to work well we often
think that every part of her body has to
be lit
lit that's not not the case the more
shadow and highlight we see
the the deeper the shot becomes and the
more three-dimensional it actually looks
so now if we turned her body this way
again we'll do it more of a close-up way
so just about there
standing sort of flat-footed yep
and now keep your body where it is and
turn your face towards me
so just perfectly this way good
now you can see though although rainy
obviously is a gorgeous girl she's got
beautiful features on her face
when we use lighting coming from the
side we call that split lighting
lighting is on one side shadow on the
other therefore it's
it's considered a very masculine quality
of light now i often refer to lighting
almost like
sweet and sour we have enough sweetness
in the face
and i often refer to the sourness of
light like masculine light that very
hard quality of light coming from the
side
i feel like you need enough sweetness in
the face
and soft features to get away with that
harsh light but i'm telling you now the
difference will be
if we have that beautiful lighting
coming uh in that direction
we turn her chin or the nose towards the
light
to a point where both eye sockets are
lit let me explain that further right
now as we go a little bit closer
so now that i've told you to turn the
body away from the light and turn the
face back in
let's look at the nuances of the face
and then how we can actually make the
face look better
based upon the direction of light and
what will work especially for women
okay rainy so just uh turn your face
this way
okay so yeah let's photograph you poorly
for a moment
so turn your face more that way good
just there
now okay so there's rainy um
i love seeing rainy in bad light because
it sort of makes me feel better about my
own insecurities there
but uh this is what we call a beautiful
girl in bad light
now now we might say well that's a great
location therefore that's why we
photograph in that in that partic
particular perspective i'm saying that's
not good enough
what you want to do is this very gently
what we're going to do now
is we're going to bring her face from
here
and just follow my hand we're going to
turn her nose towards the light source
so stop keep on going stop there okay we
call that split lighting
okay again i think that's a very
masculine quality of light i feel like
if we tip on turning her nose
until the eye socket on this side is
actually
completely lit then we're going to get a
beautiful shot of her
turn your face this way turn okay stop
there do you see how
just the corner of her eye socket needs
a bit more light let's keep on going
right there stop there and now tilt your
head this way and then drop the chin a
little bit
beautiful so now i'm not after this
heroic shot or anything like that but
you can see the catch lights in her eyes
are amazing
cheekbones and jawline are looking
amazing there as well
that there's a huge difference between
that
and that so we call this
short lighting short lighting is we're
shooting on the short side of the face
in the sense that this is the
shadow side of the face and if i was to
photograph it like this
and turn we call this the broad side of
the face
this brings out character and often
reserved for
say masculine face like a guy a guy
or perhaps if he wanted to make a
skinnier girl let's say he's a little
bit more gaunt in the face maybe look a
little bit fuller in the cheeks
but i'm yet to meet a girl who who wants
to look fuller in their face
than they actually are it's very very
rare of that to happen so chin up a
little bit tilt the face this way turn
your face in that direction and that's
it now
remember guys when it comes to lighting
it's really important to understand that
posing and lighting work in harmony so
if we come back a little bit and have a
look at this shot from this perspective
so now we're basically going to crop
just underneath her bust
and above her elbows it's really
important to understand that so
if we photograph at the peak of her bust
it's a waste of a curve i would probably
go
directly above in this case i like to go
underneath her bust and above her elbow
because once you pass the elbow you feel
like you want to see more of the arm
this becomes a portrait of somebody so
that's basically it that's how we're
doing that
all right very good so now let's now
bring those shoulders back this one as
well so bring that right back
good perfect just stay there for me
rainy
and again we sing we're turning her body
away from the light source and her face
back in
it's considered very feminine to do that
so to bring her chin
to the outer shoulder and then eyes back
so looking
back at me good
now watch what happens if we keep her
face there and we turn her body towards
a light source
turn your body this way stop there and
then hang your face this way
and then turn your face looking at me
and eyes with me
great so look at the difference turn the
body away from the light source we get
the shadow on the cleavage shadow
um on on the body and the shoulder line
and then we've got that beautiful shadow
on the side of the face
when we turn her body towards the light
source it's going to be
an issue and again for her she's very
slim
it makes it really easy but the common
denominator is
turn the body away from the light source
and turn the face back in
now what other lighting can work for a
girl well certainly we could it's
endless
there's so many different qualities of
light so many different uh styles of
lighting
but what would compliment her if we
simply change our position
in relationship to the light we're going
to get a very different quality
and let's do that right now so now what
i've done is i've got my back towards
the light source
and the light is flooding in to rainy
now
this is going to make her skin look
really soft which girls of course they
love that
if you're photographing say parents or
grandparents they're going to love it
because
you are flooding in the light what you
have to sort of imagine i often refer to
faces like landscapes
imagine as we get older we get lines in
the face we get all those little nooks
and crannies as we say
i find like like the grand canyon you
know and seeing all those lines and all
that character
by you flooding in the light you're
filling up the canyon and you're not
seeing those creases you're not seeing
those peaks and valleys
so depending on the person that you're
photographing you want to make sure
the lighting that you're using is going
to complement them in this case
girls want to look slim so the shot that
we did previously with the shadow on the
on the side of the face as close to the
camera the short side
the shadow side is great but in this
case
her skin is already flawless we're going
to make it look even more flawless
with flooding the light right into her
like this
so lean forward there for me rainy turn
your body this way so i get a little bit
of styling going on
and then lean forward with your chin
chin forward and then down a little bit
and then turn your face this way good
hold it there
okay that's beautiful i can just
change my angle here a little bit
perfect okay eyes with me beautiful
it's obviously quite tough with the
light and and how that works
but you see how what we've done is i've
actually turned her face she's not
completely facing the camera
she's actually facing right here but
she's turning her face on this
particular perspective
and that's giving us a little bit of
shadowing on this side of the face
if i wanted it more soft and more
flooded she would turn her face
perfectly at the camera let's do that
so now turn your face this way that's it
chin down
and then turn your face more this way
more good and then straighten up
good rainy turn your face more this way
that's it and turn your face there good
okay perfect okay beautiful
that's perfect so lights flooding
through looking really good now what
happens if i wanted to actually create a
bit more of a shadow
so here's what's happening we've got a
canvas background which is
dark it's not too dark but it's dark
it's going to cut away light so if i
tilt her face the top of her head
towards that particular background
we're going to create a little bit of
shadow even though that we're actually
going to photograph
on the light side of the face does that
make sense the broad side so
let's do that so ready turn this way
and turn good hold it there okay
so if you can look at rainy there now
you can see
that this canvas background is cutting
away light on this side of the face
therefore creating a shadow on her face
and eyes at me
good perfect and now
if i wanted a shadow on this side of the
face i just simply turn her
and just take your hair on from that
side
so that's it perfect good
i'll turn your face this way and turn
and then randy turn your face a bit more
towards me stop there perfect
awesome eyes at me good one second just
resetting the focus here
perfect so now we see this soft lighting
we did it first of all with a little
hint of shadow then we did it flat it
looked fantastic
then if i wanted a little bit of what we
call modeling modeling as in we're
creating
shape and we see the silhouette her
shape and depth
we turned her face towards that
background creating a bit of a shadow
and then we did it the opposite way now
really it's up to you as to which way do
you prefer
but the fact is that lighting for women
every woman is going to be a little bit
different
and and if someone was to ask me what
does good lighting even mean
in my perspective my humble opinion is
good lighting
is either flattering and or it helps
communicate the message you're trying to
convey to the viewer
in this case we're not trying to save
the world without with our photographs
we're not trying to show
depth of character and lines and those
those those wisdom lines and every line
is
tells a story we're just basically meant
for soft and flattering quality of light
of course if you were on the streets of
india and you were seeing a great
grandmother and you're seeing
this side lighting and texture and depth
and dimension and form
well that's where you'd have the light
coming from the side to show
all that all those uh all those
beautiful lines
but it really it depends on what you're
trying to go for but remember
you want to turn the body away from the
light source turn the face back in
if you are standing in where the light
source is and flooding through
well then of course you can actually
change
the perspective of where the shadow is
coming from by simply a tilt of the face
and turning the face into a darker area
now
do we always feel that we can't turn the
body towards a light source
and what are the exceptions to that rule
well let me show you now
we mentioned before that it might not be
a great idea to actually turn the body
of the girl the model the woman the
bride whoever you're photographing
towards a light source
now yes i feel like you can do that
depending on the body type so
again rainey is very slim she's got a
great figure she can get away with it
although i do prefer her
where she turns her body away from the
light source and the face back in
but if i wanted a bit of a different
perspective
i could turn her body completely towards
a light source
so that i get half her body in light and
half her body in shadow
in that way it works better so watch
this so right now what we're seeing
here is her her body's facing us
i want you to very gently pretend like
you're on a turntable and you're turning
towards the light
stop there so you can see the difference
there right so now we're broadlighting
her
she looks a little bit squarer but now
if i turn her body more this way
a bit more perfectly flat so
side on so now i get the curves one
light one side of her body is in light
one
side's in shadow so what i want her to
do she's doing it already naturally
she's actually
pointing to the toe towards the camera
so point that toe more towards me
slide the heel back in that's it bend
the knee a little bit i want you to hold
your hands a bit further behind you a
bit more
and now i want you to lean towards the
light source
that's it and then bring your hands and
elbows a little bit more back
actually good put your hands on your
hips there for me and bring your elbows
back a little bit
good so now what i'm basically seeing is
i'm seeing a gap between her elbow and
her body
i can see the outline of her bust and
her butt and i can see the legs in other
words we've got peaks and valleys a lot
more so
than we did beforehand
now if she turned her face towards us
let's do the exact same thing with her
face towards us
perfect hold it there might go a little
bit closer don't usually like cropping
right at the ankles this in my opinion
is more of a three-quarter shot so
that's great
so lean forward that way turn your body
this way good
and eyes back at me perfect hold it
beautiful
so there's a big difference between
shifting her
her weight and her body towards the
light but so much so
that we're now seeing an even split
between highlight
and shadow now how do we can combine
let's say light from a garage door or
light from an actual window
with other supplementary lighting to
give us a really cool effect
let's do that all right let's turn this
way
okay ready for this in there for you
okay so what i'm doing here to prepare
for our tutorial i've got a couple of
ice lights so the ice light was my
invention in case you don't know
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to use soft light coming through
the garage door again this could be
likened to a soft box or a window
it doesn't really matter we have this
direction of light coming through this
way
but what we're going to do is we're
going to look at the light the way it
falls on her
and then maybe add a bit of a hair light
and possibly even a background light to
give us an idea
so rainy if you want to just look at me
there for a moment okay so turn this way
and turn your body away from the light
source a bit more and then turn your
face back in
a bit more and then your chin to your
shoulder good
okay hold it there and then look at me
down turn this way
turn this way good
i'm going to shoot just horizontally now
she has blonde hair so
we can easily separate her from the
background it's not a problem
but i find that you know if you want
even more separation that's where you
can introduce a hair light
and then that's of course where you can
introduce a background light as well
depends on what you want
now there is there are endless ways of
doing this at the end of the day you
just got to pick one
all right so let's have a look so now
just to remind you how we light the face
let's start with your face away from the
light there rainy
okay so at the moment lighting is not so
great on her there
let's just hold that for a second
now very gently i want you to turn this
waist up there
so right now we don't have a face
completely lit but then we turn her face
to a point where
the eye socket her right eye socket or
camera left is completely lit
let's start again come from here and
very slowly follow my hand
stop tilt the face why do i tilt the
face and turn the chin to the shoulder
it adds a bit more finesse it's quite
feminine remember what we said
if we pose her chin to her outer
shoulder and eyes back at the camera
it's very feminine
if you did that with a guy it would look
very feminine which you don't want
okay so bring your shoulders back a
little bit more and your elbows back a
little bit more
good just want to do that perfect and
then eyes at me there rainey
gorgeous hold it there beautiful good
all right so now we've taken that shot
now let's introduce some other elements
let's introduce a hair light so what i'm
doing is i'm preparing
an ice light at the back with some barn
doors um
and i want a bit of a beam of light to
separate her from the background we're
so already somewhat doing that the fact
that she's
got blonde hair great that separates her
from the background automatically
but a bit of hair light would add that
little bit of extra you know edge and
finesse
to what we're doing and and look a
little bit more professional
uh i want to say professional i mean
just you can tell that this has been
lit by a a pro photographer um
and right now i'm just preparing this uh
to the point where we get to it so
all right what we'll do so we can
amplify what's going on i'll turn off
the ambient
lights already in this garage get it
ready so we can reestablish where we
were
and then what we got to so turn your
body a little bit away and then turn
your face back in to chin to the
shoulder
just lean forward just bring your one
foot out there that's it good
and then chin to the shoulder good turn
your face this way fantastic
all right let's have a look at what we
got here bring this left elbow back
that's great and then bring your right
elbow back as well
good hold it there
okay let's just retake that shot so just
eyes at me there for me hold it there
good beautiful so we've got lighting a
strong direction of light on this side
we've got beautiful catch lights in the
eyes
and then we've got a shadow on that side
of the face so now what i want to do
is introduce that hair light so if you
can go back in that same position
the important thing is guys that you do
not want
this light to actually touch her nose or
the top of her head
hair's okay but the minute the light
hits the top of the head
or tip of the nose it's going to look a
little bit weird so draw an imaginary
line from this light
to where she is and then we can go there
accordingly so turn your face back there
so i can just tell so where it was
top of your head sort of towards the
garage towards the car there
good all right and i think
we're good right there
okay so let's have a look at the
difference
beautiful turn your face this way for me
rainy good hold it there
hold it there hold it bring both elbows
back your right elbow especially bit
more
good hold it there eyes at me now i can
see the light stand
from behind there and even though this
is more of a tutorial than after these
incredible finesse shots we're just
going to get rid of it anyway great hold
it there for me hold it
eyes at me perfect so we see a big
difference between no hair light and
then
with hair light i would probably dim
that down a little bit so let's just
come down
and dim that down a couple of notches so
it's on the highest power setting
just use your judgment in terms of what
you think looks and feels good and make
sure there's detail in the hair in the
back there
turn the face that way again that's
perfect yeah that's looking a little bit
more subtle
fantastic hold it there arms off the
body eyes at me
perfect hold it good so now we're going
to introduce a light in the background
so we're going to turn this light on
that's going to work well for us as well
let's see what we get i need that a
little bit lower
so let's always take your time guys
um no different than a hair and makeup
artist spending
a lot of time with what they do why
should we be rushed
it's the same thing right i sort of
want a bit of a glamorous look and i
quite like the fact it almost looks like
a spotlight too so
i'm going to go closer so i can get rid
of the actual
light source there and
take a micro shuffle this way stop there
good lean this way turn your face this
way
again chin more to the shoulder top your
head that way good eyes at me
beautiful hold it there for me hold it
good
bring both elbows back right back and
drop that arm so i can't see it that
right hand
perfect eyes at me beautiful hold it
gorgeous and let's come a little bit
closer actually hold on
perfect so elbows out there raining
perfect hold it there for me hold it
all right so look at the difference so
we just basically have
light coming through again this could be
likened to a window light
a strobe whatever it may be a big light
source coming through
we turn her face until a point where we
get both
eye sockets completely lit that way now
we get a shadow on this side of the face
it's become the short side the narrow
side the shadow side as we call it
and then she looks back in the camera
we've got beautiful catch lights in the
eyes
then we add a hair light we soften that
light there as well
and then we add a bit of a background
light that bring that
all together and that's what it's all
about guys is just
being able to complement who's in front
of your camera and it look
exceptional all right guys hope you
enjoyed that remember of course we could
have done this a thousand different ways
i wanted to give you an understanding
of what will complement the female form
as well as the face
and give you an idea that lighting
shouldn't be that difficult
remember wherever the light is coming
from turn the body away from the light
source to a point
where you get a shadow on the cleavage
in the middle of the dress or whatever
the body type whatever it basically may
be
and then turn the face back into the
light until you get both eye sockets
completely lit remember the chin to the
outer shoulder and eyes back of the
camera
is going to be a very feminine look if
you want softer if you don't want
if you want less wrinkles if you have a
girl with acne or anything like that
make sure the light floods from the
front if you want a bit more character
of course it comes from the side
quite simply you always have to look at
the face look at the direction of light
and understand how these how these two
things meet hope that gave you a really
good perspective
enjoy guys and remember repetition
experience and practice will be your
best teacher
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed that video
also do me a favor give me a thumbs up
please subscribe and don't forget to
click on that bell for notifications of
future episodes
also leave me a comment i'd love to hear
from you answer any of your questions
and stay connected and remember you
don't have to be the best
you just got to be better than last week
you